we keep using this word responsiveness
but what are we actually talking about
people use many different devices to
access the internet everything from
large desktops to laptops netbooks or
maybe even tablets or phones in fact
more and more people every year are
accessing the Internet primarily through
their phones or through their tablets in
fact right now there's a pretty good
chance that you're watching this video
on your phone or tablet and every one of
these devices uses a different size
screen to show you the same content but
what do we mean by different size of
course we're not talking about the
physical size of the screen the height
and width of it we're talking about its
resolution specifically we want to talk
about the resolution of the screen in
pixels today
we commonly see desktop screens with
widths of say 1440 pixels or 1920 pixels
some large screens today are even going
as large as 2560 pixels wide but not too
long ago people were using screens that
were only 1024 pixels wide or 1200
pixels wide for screens like these it
was common to set max width of 960
pixels meaning that websites were only
960 pixels wide the reason it wasn't the
full 1024 or 1200 was to actually leave
room on the side of the screen for
scroll bars to this day creating content
with the width of 960 pixels is still
pretty common on larger screens of 1920
pixels or 1440 pixels you can simply
Center the 960 pixel wide content to
make sure it still looks good this max
width CSS style allows us to ensure that
our content won't be any bigger than 960
pixels or whatever value we choose
regardless of the size screen that we're
using following the principles of
responsive design means that your
website isn't fixed to a single size it
doesn't matter the type of device the
page is going to respond and resize
correctly to make sure everything looks
great and is legible it's also important
to note that for devices like tablets
and phones users are using their thumbs
not a mouse to manipulate the page which
means that you may need to change your
layout a bit further to make it easier
to use this is called adaptive design
for now though we're simply going to
focus on responsiveness which means
simply changing the size of the page to
fit
let's use the reddit homepage to see an
example of responsive design pay
attention to this left column containing
all of the posts on the homepage I'll
resize the screen and we can see that
the post on the left side got smaller as
we made the browser window smaller these
posts are responsive they're changing
their width based on the width of the
browser and note that the column on the
right wasn't responsive the width here
is the same as the width when the
browser is fullscreen